i don't know how i'm gonna do this i
don't know if i'll be able to do this
but if you can see me i guess i did do
it wish me luck
[Music]
hi i'm ayo and i'm a private chef which
usually means i have a massive budget
however today tasty has challenged me to
create a thanksgiving dinner for six
people for 30 dollars i'm gonna go
shopping and see what i can figure out
okay we came in under budget multiple
stores a few hacks here and there but i
was able to get everything i needed for
my thanksgiving dinner for
29.93 i have a few pantry staples that i
can use today to help me out i have
olive oil and i have salt and pepper i
don't know how i'm going to do this i
got a few tips and tricks i kind of have
a plan but let's get started
[Music]
i'm going to start with dessert because
i'm going to show you how to save time
and show you how to save some money so i
am going to make a cheaters meringue for
a patty pie i'm using a patty pie
because i want to kind of stay true to
my roots with this and i'm southern we
do not eat pumpkin pie we eat sweet
potato pie so i'm going to start with a
pre-made
patty pie to jazz up this pie a little
i'm actually going to make a cheaters
meringue so i have three room
temperature egg whites
marshmallow fluff and i'm going to whip
this up into soft peaks and then slowly
add in my marshmallow fluff it smells
really good
this is not my ministry which is why
we're doing a cheaters meringue so now
i'm gonna add the marshmallow fluff and
i'm gonna add it slowly about a third at
a time so i don't deflate the egg whites
so this is shiny we have some nice stiff
peaks which is exactly what you want i'm
gonna take large chunks pile it very
very very high
and then i'm just gonna create like some
little hills and valleys some nice peaks
higher than moraine close to the guys it
smells so good you know she's a big girl
she got a lot of a lot of body so i'm
gonna go put this in the oven at 350
degrees for about 10 to 12 minutes just
to get it brown
[Music]
we don't have money for a whole turkey
there's also only six guests coming to
this dinner so i'm going to use a turkey
breast i got it pre-seasoned which saved
me a ton of money on spice i won't say i
don't trust that they fully seasoned it
but i will say don't judge me or this
turkey so i'm just gonna give it a
little extra i can hear a lot of the
chefs and foodies
making this face about pre-season it
saved us money and it's cajun seasoning
which i feel like is almost always a
safe bet so now i'm gonna sear the skin
side first in an already very very hot
pan so inside this pan i already have
two tablespoons of olive oil and what
you're looking for is just a nice golden
brown delicious crispy crispy crispy
skin make sure the meat is nice and dry
before it goes in your pan this is what
we are looking for crispy skin
golden brown delicious
so now i'm gonna add my aromatics to the
pan this will help us out a lot later so
i have three celery stalks that i cut
into thirds
half of one large yellow onion and six
garlic cloves peeled so i'm gonna take
this guy to the oven at 350 for about 75
minutes until he gets to about 165
degrees but don't worry our turkey's not
gonna be dry i'm gonna baste it in its
own juices about every 30 minutes or so
so we're going to keep her nice and
moist and ready to go and now we're
going to get into my favorite part and
my whole reason for going to
thanksgiving besides
[Music]
so the first thing i'm going to make is
this cornbread dressing i know dressing
versus cornbread is a whole thing i am
southern we make dressing i've never
actually had stuffing i always thought
it was like stuffed in the turkey and
cooked that way and i never was
interested in like bird butt bread
so the first thing i'm gonna do is cook
eight ounces of pork sausage in this pan
i already have it hot i've added some
olive oil to it so i'm just gonna start
here my pork sausage also has some spice
to it which is a good way to again save
money on seasoning but get a little
extra flavor so i'm gonna cook this
sausage for about seven to eight minutes
just until i get it nice and brown and
caramelized you want it cooked all the
way because it'll give us a lot of
texture okay so now i'm gonna add in my
celery that same onion we used earlier
and two garlic cloves that we just
minced up and we're just gonna cook this
until the veg gets soft and everything
starts to smell really good i'm also
gonna salt this just a tad as we're
moving through it really kick up that
spicy flavor that's in our sausage so my
vegetables are all soft and now i'm
gonna add my box cornbread stuffing
normally i would make this myself i'd
make my cornbread first it would be a
whole thing but i had thirty dollars and
we don't have that much time okay this
is looking pretty good so now i'm going
to add a cup and a half of boiling water
and four tablespoons of butter see tell
you always gonna make it taste good so
now i'm gonna cover this for about five
minutes and let it fluff up and absorb
all of that butter we just put in okay
this is actually surprisingly smelling
pretty good i'm really impressed with
this the one thing dressing and stuffing
both have in common is a nice crispy
topping so i'm going to move this from
the stove top to an oven safe casserole
dish and i'm going to broil it for about
one to two minutes just to give it a
little crunch
all right so next i am going to make
mashed potatoes the craziest thing about
this entire dish is that i got 10 pounds
of mashed potatoes for a dollar and 98
cents and i'm only using about four
pounds of potatoes so after you cook for
everybody your guest leaves make you
some mashed potatoes for the next day
and growing up weirdly enough my family
didn't do mashed potatoes i think we're
more of a rice family but i love mashed
potatoes so when i started cooking i
think of my 9 or 10 i brought the mashed
potatoes i'm going to use a mandolin
because it's faster but if this scares
you which it should if you're not used
to using it you can absolutely use a
knife the best way to cook these is to
cut them very very thin so i'm just
going to slice this entire bowl and then
we're going to move on to boiling them
so you always want to start your
potatoes off in cold water and i'm just
going to salt the water and i'm going to
turn this up all right so my potatoes
are cooked they are strained and now it
is time to turn them into mashed
potatoes if you don't have a rice fair
you can use a potato masher there's
nothing wrong with a rustic potato you
could mash them with a fork just
whatever you have on hand but these are
fancy so i'm going to use this ricer so
another great money saving tip
sour cream typically i would add like
heavy cream or buttermilk something to
give you that tang and the smooth
mouthfeel you get from dairy we don't
have money for that y'all i have a cup
and a half of melted but yes a cup and a
half at thanksgiving of melted butter
and i'm going to add that to my potatoes
i really like doing it by hand because
you get to see it come together and you
just you cook it with a little bit of
love okay so this looks really good we
have turkey we have sweet potatoes and
honestly i think we need some vegetables
so i'm gonna move on to making us some
green beans
so the first thing we're gonna do is
take three cloves of smashed garlic and
we're gonna saute them in our pan with
the green beans for a thanksgiving meal
typically i would make collard greens
but
we can't afford collard greens not
making gbc i do not make casseroles
never casserole so i'm just going to hit
them with a little salt and then i'm
actually going to steam them in this
chicken stock which is a great way to
add a lot of flavor you don't want to
steam them till they're very soft you
want them to still have a little bit of
bite my green beans look good they're
nice and tender for the oolala part i'm
going to zest one entire lemon and you
want to do this at the end because you
don't want them to get brown you want
them to keep that bright vibrant green
color if you feel like you have a firmer
lemon a good tip is just to give it a
little roll and add the lemon juice
these guys are looking good just give
them a little toss
and i'm going to hit them with a little
bit of salt i think we're ready to go
okay
last thing we're gonna make is the gravy
i'm a dipper i always need some sort of
sauce and if you've ever had turkey you
know it needs some sort of salt
apparently so do the people who seasoned
our turkey because it came with a
pre-made gravy pack i feel the judgment
but we saved our drippings and it's a
cajun gravy and i actually really think
we're going to be able to make this
happen you guys so i have one cup of my
turkey drippings and water basically
drippings are just all those juices we
were basting the turkey in and all of
those
yummy smells from our aromatics all of
that then this dripping which is going
to make this gravy taste like we really
put some effort into it so we're
literally going to boil them boil out
the water boil out anything we don't
need and everything that's left is going
to be very highly concentrated it's
going to be thick rich i think my gravy
is good one thing i like to do is put a
little spoon in it if it coats to back
your spoon
it will coat your meat which means you
are all good to go all right this gravy
is done i'm gonna go plate everything
and we're gonna see if it actually
tastes good or if it tastes like i spent
30 dollars so
let's go try it
[Music]
this
is what
29.93
is worth the food looks like i was able
to make the mashed potatoes with real
butter and sour cream so i got that tang
i got my dairy in there i was able to
make this stuffing which is surprisingly
really really really beautiful and we
got a nice crunch to it it looks good it
looks like it took us a lot of time
green beans just to liven up the party
we needed some freshness y'all we have
to eat some vegetables in this pot do
y'all see did y'all see this pie the pie
is stunning it looks like i actually
really really took my time and as far as
my guests know i did surprisingly i
actually had enough money to add a
little bit of cranberry sauce and i just
added some orange zest to it to give it
the extra oomph all right so i got my
plate quality control time so i'm going
to give this turkey a try okay you guys
this is not bad like for the price point
this is actually pretty good i'm trying
my mashed potatoes
okay those are amazing anything with a
cup and a half of butter and it should
be amazing and it is i'm very proud of
this i'm ayo cherry let me know if you
have any other challenges you want us to
do thank you so much for watching and
have a happy thanksgiving
oh yes
[Music]
you